[Musique]
fred michel terrot bonjour bonjour
monsieur k oui je mange ou aux auditeurs
de martinique 1ère un président réélu
samedi samedi dernier à la tête de l'est
républicain de martinique vous étiez le
seul candidat pour cette fonction de
président de la section locale
mais le vote concerné aussi le reste des
instances dirigeantes de votre parti en
martinique alors est ce que là il ya eu
quelques changements sans entrer dans
les détails fred messieurs le tir ou
c'est toute l'équipe dirigeante qui a
été renouvelée d'un bloc mais réélu
aussi d'un bloc
alors permettez-moi monsieur kawoush de
féliciter michael stanislas qui est
champion cycliste de la caraïbe
ce sociétaire de lui c est ce donc à
représenter dignement la martinique
donc on le félicite alors pour revenir
sur votre question donc je veux remercie
déjà tous les électeurs qui se sent
position sur mon nom et plus qui ont
permis aussi le renouvellement de
l'équipe dirigeante vous l'avez dit l'ia
des nouveaux il ya des gens qui ont été
renouvelé on dire à 50 50 c'est à dire
qu'il ya 50% de nouveaux dirigeants de
nouveaux cadres cette fédération et 50%
de d'anciens qui sont revenus pour
passer le témoin justement comment
expliquez-vous que personne n'ait voulu
se présenter face à vous a pas du tout
des musiques candidat mais pour se
présenter à la présidence il faut avoir
des parrainages donc il faut être
supporté par écrit par un certain nombre
de militants donc il ya des volontés
n'ont pas n'ont pas eu assez de larry
nage pour pouvoir aller jusqu'à à
l'élection quid du secrétariat
territoriales qui revenait
quelque temps à karine rousseau est là
elle a laissé là la fonction vous disait
il ya quelques mois que c'est laurent
wauquiez qui devait décider de la suite
d'un corner ton en accord avec la
nouvelle direction qui serait élue dans
notre fédération qui a été désigné hier
de notre fédération alors le président
invoqué poids maintenant désigner un
nouveau ou une nouvelle secrétaire
territorial
donc ça va se faire dans les jours qui
viennent le ou la secrétaire et
territoriales comme elle travaille par
rapport au président c'est quoi c'est un
binôme c'est un binôme à la tête de la
fédération en importance et les missions
que nous aurons à conduire avec cette
nouvelle équipe formée les nouveaux
militants
puisqu'il faut former des personnes qui
seront amenés à prendre des
responsabilités dans les conseils
municipaux dans le conseil territorial
donc il faut former des militants et
puis monter au créneau sur les grands
sujets d'actualité qui nous concerne à
la martinique sé c'est le rôle d'un
parti politique et c'est ce que nous
comptons faire encore avec plus de force
dans l'est dans les semaines à venir
vous voyez comment nous sommes m'attaque
matraque et comment les retraités sont
sont malmenés par le gouvernement actuel
puisque le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
est en diminution les chefs
d'entreprises aussi les petits
entrepreneurs notamment sont maltraités
puisque avec un suppression de la tva
npr donc ils ont un gros manque à gagner
et puis plus récemment vous avez vu que
les classes moyennes là aussi auront du
souci à se faire puisque il y aura la
suppression de l'abattement de 30% des
impôts donc c'est sûr que nous aurons
deux grands sujets a à défendre il
faudrait se battre parce que franchement
le gouvernement actuel est en train de
mettre l'économie de la martinique
amor amor alors oui si tu veux quand
vous su quand vous supprimer
l'abattement par exemple l'abattement
des impôts quelques qui à 20 l'impôt
2000 supprimer c'est peut-être pas le
terme qui convient exactement fred
michel tir ou alors est-ce que vous non
c'est une réforme qui vise
semble-t-il à un suc à oui je vous
n'avez peut-être pas bien suivi les
travaux de la commission des lois
il s'agit plus ou moins et super
simplement de supprimer l'abattement de
30% ça veut dire quoi concrètement
monsieur carouge quelqu'un qui devait
payer 1000 lahoud c'est une réforme qui
va concerner a priori d'après ce que le
gouvernement dit et le président de la
république lui même va concerner
seulement 4% des foyers fiscaux les plus
aisés monsieur donc l'abattement n'est
pas supprimée pour tout le monde ça
devrait toucher une catégorie des tribus
apprenant inexactes et il s'agit de
diminuer le plafond de la vente âge
alors est ce que je veux dire prenant un
exemple supprime l'abattement c'est
peut-être allé trop vite en ont besoin
dans prenons un exemple quelqu'un qui
paye 1000 euros d'impôts seront faits
l'abattement de 30% comme donc ça veut
dire qu'il paie 700 euros quand on va
supprimer cet abattement il va re payer
1000 euros d'impôts ça veut dire que
vous aurez une augmentation de 3,6 mais
ça ne concerne pas tous les martiniquais
pour tous les contribuables marque
monsieur k ce n'est pas a priori c'est
monsieur cas où ce n'est pas encore
votée là justement c'est ce que je vous
dis alors moi je vous dis c'est pas
procès d'intention vous faites maison
des questions soyons solidaires monsieur
carouge
aujourd'hui vous avez un gouvernement
qui nous annonce depuis un an que on va
supprimer la taxe d'habitation et que
les collectivités auront des revenus
puisque il va on est passé à autre chose
aujourd'hui n'est pas en mairie ce que
je veux vous dire c'est qu'il ne faut
pas croire sur parole ce qu'on vous dit
donc on fait de la com vous dis que ça
va suivre ça va concerner uniquement 4 %
des gens je demande à voir ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que il avait
annoncé le gouvernement
une diva remplacement de la taxe
d'habitation s'est pas encore prévu
s'est pas encore dit on ne sait pas par
quoi ce sera ses placements pour les
icônes d'emploi il ne faut pas quoi
prendre pour argent comptant ce que le
président ma peau vous dis ne faut pas
prendre pour argent comptant donc
j'attends de voir ce qui sera votée mais
en amont je me bats pour la martinique
de telle sorte que le matraquage qui
entraîne ce fait assureurs sur la
population n'ait pas lieu parce que moi
je ne crois pas et je ne prends pas pour
argent comptant ce qui est annoncé c'est
tout à fait votre liberté votre droite
ce qui est amusant qui me suis calmé je
mets aida suite dont certains ne
s'étaient pas présent monsieur
j'apprends temps parce que vous avez
envie d'aller vite mais il faut que les
auditeurs comprennent que si l'ensemble
des parlementaires des territoires
d'outre-mer se sont battus par seulement
nous parlementaires martiniquais mais il
comprit lénaïc adam députée de guyane et
de la république en marche
nadia ramassamy députés l ère de la
réunion tous unanimement se sont battus
pour que cette réforme annoncée par le
gouvernement n'ait pas lieu
c'est parce qu'ils sentent bien que là
il y en guise ou roche et que on veut
plus au moins est simplement je le dit m
amoureux l'économie des départements
d'autres m'ont dit le gouvernement veut
nous couillonner quoi c'est pour parler
un petit peu dans le langage courant et
je vous aimais que les mêmes dernier
attendait mais quand même des
parlementaires comme freddy garcia oui
le sénateur patient qui est quelqu'un de
très objectif avait quelques doutes et
dans votre antenne ça c'est entendu
justement et vous avez interviewé le
sénateur georges patient
on voit bien les vins il est parfait
appliquée alors qu'il est un soutien
affiché de la république en marche alors
vous ne croyez pas que cette recette
finalement parce que c'est ce qui est
annoncé par le chef de l'état et le
gouvernement vous ne croyez pas non plus
donc que cette recette
je crois à peu près 70 millions d'euros
ça a été calculé que cette recette dont
qui sera récupérée par l'état avec cette
réforme de l'abattement fiscal en
outre-mer cette somme 10 le gouvernement
est appelé à être réinvesti non
seulement je dans les territoires sur
des projets dans les domaines de
l'agriculture du numérique ou encore
super u
non seulement je ne le crois pas mais
c'est totalement illégal il ya un
principe élémentaire du doigt budgétaire
qui veut dire l'unicité du budget et la
non affectation des ressources
il est totalement interdit point
gouvernement de prendre une partie des
ressources des impôts sur le revenu et
de l'affecter au développement de la
corse de la cour est de la martinique
c'est totalement illégal donc non
seulement je vous dis que je ne crois
pas ce qui est annoncé mais de plus le
projet de loi est totalement illégal et
contraire aux principes élémentaires du
droit budgétaire et j'invite les
parlementaires à saisir si jamais par
extraordinaire ce ce texte passe de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel pour
attaquer
ce projet dont on a bien compris que les
républicains de martinique sont vent
debout contre cette réforme de toute de
l'abattement et jacques gabel j'appelle
solennellement à tous les élus de toutes
tendances et tous les martiniquais à se
réveiller à se mettre debout parce que
je nous sens un peu endormi face à ce
vent qui entraîne se lever contre nous
est ce parce que ça pourrait toucher
effectivement les plus visés que ça gêne
touchait tout le monde ça va toucher
tout le monde puisque ce gouvernement
s'attaque aux retraités les retraités
qui ont des petites retraites ont vu
leurs revenus diminuer les petites
entreprises qui ne peuvent plus
bénéficier de la tva npr
ça touche tout le monde monsieur k oui
ça ne touche pas uniquement les hauts
revenus comme le gouvernement semble
vouloir l'indiqué plus globalement cette
visite ce séjour de travail d'emmanuel
macron qui a commencé d'ailleurs par la
martinique en est allé ensuite en
guadeloupe puis 1 à saint-martin pour se
rendre compte de la reconstruction après
d'aider les cyclones de l'an dernier
plus globalement cette visite d'
emmanuel macron chez nous comment vous
l'appréciez je les dis sur les antennes
je le redis aujourd'hui
c'est très bien que président de la
république de vienne j'aurais préféré
qu'il réunisse les élus dans un an une
réunion de travail et nous inviter un
dîner républicain
encore une fois un dîner c'est très bien
mais ce n'est pas un cadre adéquat pour
travailler nous avions suffisamment de
sujets à avancer et à discuter avec la
mise à la république les sargasses le
chlordécone le matraquage fiscal
donc je voudrais suggérer jouet préféré
qu'il nous a reçus dans le cadre d'une
réunion de travail
cela n'a pas été le cas je le lui ai dit
et j'espère que
la prochaine fois nous pourrons le
rencontrer dans un cadre plus adéquat
alors on achève une année 2010 8 qui a
été une année sans élection 1 en
campagne électorale le majeur mise à
part les élections internes comme vous
par exemple qu'il venait d'être élu
président des républicains de martinique
et 2019 ça repart avant 2000 val et les
municipales qui se prépare d'ores et
déjà 2019 ça repart avec les élections
européennes vous allez vous vous y
engager notre part dit bien évidemment
sera dans la bataille des élections
européennes et les élections municipales
aussi c'est pour cette raison que nous
préparons déjà et avec ces élections
internes nous avons donc mis notre parti
en ordre de marche avec nos délégués de
circonscription qui ont été élus donc
les tout nouveaux lionel jolie je les
cite maurice christine et liens de
saint-alban et charles denis coupe est
qu'ils auront à charge de faire porter
la parole du parti dans leurs
circonscriptions législatives
merci fred michel terrot d'avoir
participé à ce soit au caddie bonne
journée à tous derrière s'ils avouent
bonne journée à tous et à toutes
[Musique]